okay so I'm Bram Cohen I'm the founder
and chief scientist at BitTorrent Inc
I created the BitTorrent protocol
sitting in my living room in my
underwear with no academic affiliation
oddly enough so I'm going to talk about
BitTorrent live so BitTorrent is this is
again a bandwidth based solution because
of the various things you could try and
distribute it turns out there's plenty
of CPU there's plenty of storage there's
plenty of lots of things where there
isn't plenty of as bandwidth so
BitTorrent is all about bandwidth and
BitTorrent live is in a similar vein and
it's about trying to do a live video
streaming like on television same way
people still to this day consume most of
their video content and the problem here
is how do we do it peer-to-peer how do
we make it so one person can be
broadcasting and a million people can be
watching and it all works well it sounds
like a reasonably well-defined problem
here's the general goal of what you want
to have accomplished as the number of
viewers goes up in a non peer-to-peer
system the amount of bandwidth use goes
up and a BitTorrent live it caps out at
around ten ten times the Bary of the
stream no matter how many peers you have
so in terms of where the problem is
there's CPU usage that's not a big deal
get your asymptotics right I have the
whole thing random pythons Abagail
bandwidth overhead of course matters you
can waste around twenty to thirty
percent most protocols do stuff like
that not a big deal
a necessary Headroom is a little
different from bandwidth overhead
necessary headroom includes the amount
of extra space you need above and beyond
your overhead in order to actually
function properly you won't be using it
all the time but if you don't have it
everything is going to fall apart sooner
or later that's done really thirty to
fifty percent which compounds on top of
the twenty to thirty percent bandwidth
overhead that you have so you're
typically looking at around a hundred
percent overall combined overhead and
you definitely need robustness against
fast pure turn
you should really engineer the whole
thing from scratch to do that and you
definitely need congestion control
that's getting to be hard because you
need to make it shift over quickly which
regular congestion control doesn't do at
all how many of you are familiar with
TCPS congestion control okay you're all
gonna find this hella weird security is
very hard you need to use some slightly
new ish crypto gunk I'll explain that
not that weird I didn't do it myself and
latency is the real problem here's the
big issue you want it to be that
something is happening right now and
right now as in in about five seconds
everybody's viewing it even if there's
like a million peers turns out latency
is the big issue
liyan see totally dominates everything
the other peer-to-peer live video
systems people have made typically have
Layton sees around if they're really
really good 30 seconds more typically
like five minutes that's not really very
life that's more like tape-delayed
latency sucks liyan see it's kind of
like dealing with like motor efficiency
with thermodynamic things everything
adds to it there's no cheating around it
it's this quantitative value everything
you do adds to it there's no way of just
throwing an asymptotic about worrying
about it and stop worrying about it all
of your constants matter it's horrible
all right so this is generally the
overall architecture there's an input
camera it does something to the origin
server which speaks rtmp to what I'm
calling the source which is one of my
servers those speak BitTorrent live
protocols all the peers which then speak
rtmp to a flash player in a web browser
and then it gets displayed reasonably
straightforward architecture integrates
with the web my goal is to make it so
someone once they've got it installed it
doesn't know they're using it they go to
web pages that use it it plays they
don't know the difference kind of like
flash in general yes
no well in theory or in terms of actual
practice today well in theory no not at
all I don't really care in terms of
actual practice today you're basically
stuck with h.264 on flash if you want
consistent playback everywhere because
flash is the only thing that's widely
available the general pissing matches
around licensing of h.264 and its
inclusion in html5 resulted in this
wonderful thing of everyone being free
of their dependence on directly on h.264
and instead they're dependent directly
on flash thanks google alright so in
terms of basics here the broadcaster
that is on the origin server they use
any old encoder that they want flash
media live encoder open broadcaster
xsplit Wirecast these are all things
that we've seen people use hopefully it
uses x264 under the hood x264 supports
vb v vb v means that you can actually
control the bitrate in a reasonable
manner spike eNOS in bandwidth is very
bad for this protocol it's just a bad
thing to have happen because peers but
just weirdly to it they don't quite know
what to do even in theory even if my
protocol is better at handling it it
would still be a major problem you don't
want when something's kind of running at
the limit across all peers uploading as
fast as it can for there to be a sudden
spike it'll overload it and it's very
hard to get out of a bad situation once
you're in it of course most things do
use x264 most things don't actually have
any pass-through of the parameters to
the encoder to actually send to the x264
implementation that they're using thanks
guys real helpful
of course we sent to the sourcing
application via rtmp and I personally
have essentially zero interest in video
codecs
so I treat the data as a black box and I
take each packet and I remember the
contents of that packet and the time
that I got the packet and I resolved to
try and replay that exact as exactly as
I can on the Play
backside Albia delayed someone alright
so there's the series of steps that you
need to go through in order to to do
streaming and I'm just gonna follow like
the life cycle of a packet here more or
less so first off was encoding I just
covered that next you need to batch up
your data and sign it so every quarter
of a second you take all the data that
you have and batch it all up you compact
it into a bunch of packets like you see
in this diagram here each one of these
here payloads would actually potentially
have multiple rtmp pilots span inside of
it that it spans and they're all just
designed to be about the same size just
a little bit less than an MTU and then
you use a hash tree you see here binary
hash tree and sign with Ed two five five
one nine that makes it so you've got in
each and every packet you have 64 bytes
of overhead for the at 255 one nine
signature and 12 bytes for each level of
tree I just kind of decided to truncate
my things in the middle here so save
myself a few bytes because this is
overhead for every level of tree for
every single packet so in principle I
could have gone a lot less than that I
was a little worried about blah blah
blah attacks I just decided on twelve
and someone's gonna scream at me no
matter how I truncate that so that was
the value I used by using this
combination of things I managed to make
it so that I can actually literally sign
every single packet that comes through
and still not use a huge amount of
bandwidth overhead but I did in fact
need to use at 2:55 one night and I
still haven't switched to sha 3 which I
really ought to do yes
the percentage overhead of bytes on the
wire is let me see so the serve depends
partially whether you include the like
UDP overhead as well so that's like 28
bytes and there's 64 bytes but suppose
you wind up with roughly let's say 100
bytes of overhead
to you is like 1200 bytes plus so yeah
well less than 10% you have bigger
issues with just necessary Headroom that
you need but the overall overhead is
quite under control here actually CPU is
a little bit more of an issue I didn't
in fact have to use at 255 109 I'm not
just being goofy for that and I'm
switching it to use the ref 10
implementation because half my CPU is
going to a do five five one nine right
now
you know you verify signatures on every
single packet it's yes users already I
don't have control of the machine but my
software needs to run on every random
bit of garbage on the internet well
flash isn't doing that part but this has
to run on like mobile phones and
different architectures and boards I I'm
stuck with the garbage and given I have
these home net connections where people
are running other applications behind
the same net connection and they're on
Wi-Fi that has a high failure rates I'm
stuck with the garbage it's my problem
to see the thing is packet based
networking is the absolute worst form of
networking except for all the others
like no one in their right mind would
actually design it global communications
with no concept of connectivity or
guarantees or anything like that built
into it whatsoever
but it turns out the best way to
actually build the network is to build
it in exactly that way with the
assumption that some engineer will
figure out that problems that some
engineer would be me over here so so
that there's while I was working on this
someone asked me at one point what my
approach was because I was claiming kind
of ridiculous benchmarks which I could
actually get him straight in the wild
out by the way but I was claiming kind
of ridiculous benchmarks and so he asked
me how my architecture work because he
was saying you can't possibly have less
than a 30 second end to end delay and he
kind of had a reasonable rough sketch of
why that was I'm like well you're making
us
functions here in your model that aren't
true of how I do things and he asked me
what I meant I'm like what can you name
a protocol that has high robustness and
low latency and he didn't know what I
was getting at and it's like well I
didn't say that it needed you know
efficiency or congestion control so if
you want a protocol that has high
robustness and low latency and it's
actually its overhead isn't really all
that bad either
you have this protocol where every peer
has three connections to other three
bi-directional connections to other
peers and every time it gets a piece of
data from one peer it sends it to the
other two if it's never seen it before
this is what you call a screamer
protocol
it has 100% overhead it has no
congestion control however very high
robustness very low latency works great
so my idea here my secret sauce just
about the most embarrassingly stupid
piece of secret sauce I've ever had and
a new project I've ever done my secret
sauce here that I thought of in 2008
which was actually the thing got me
thinking hey maybe I could make a live
protocol this was literally my big idea
was hey I know how about ice cream the
data out I don't know
10% it appears and then do something a
little more controlled to the rest of
them and that way I'll get the high
robustness and low latency of a screamer
protocol while keeping the fact that it
has no congestion control and it has
high overhead under control by only
doing it for a small fraction of all my
traffic this was my big idea because it
was very obvious to me that tree based
protocols were way not going to work
just the way the failures cascade is
just not happening at all I don't know
why this was so obvious to me and not
anybody else and but it wasn't anyway my
idea here is to combine the best aspects
of a screamer in a tree based protocol
which is what I've done so first I'll
follow you scream data out to 1/6 of the
Pierce so turns out you scream to more
than 10% of the peers you scream to like
18% of the peers or 1/6 this is what
happens there are six what I call clubs
so every
piece of data has a sequence number if
you want to know the club associated
with that piece of data you take the
sequence number modulo six every peer is
associated with a club basically
assigned randomly when you check in with
the tracker there's a BitTorrent style
tracker it'll suggest a club for you it
just rotates through them increments
over the last one it suggested to
somebody try and get reasonably even
distribution doesn't really matter all
that much so so you have the source
which is a member of all clubs unlike
every other peer which is about who are
members of exactly one called if you
read the patent it'll say every peer as
a member of two clubs don't worry about
it
the the but the peers then scram to each
other and then for the last hop and only
the last hop does it send a in a more
controlled manner and five out of the
six peers get it that way a little less
cuz the source says to a bunch but tiny
about less in a very big swarm okay any
questions about that
everybody got it okay all right I said
that oh okay
so there's this big difference between
the last top and the not last top in
terms of prioritization if you're
familiar with BitTorrent protocol most
people who are familiar with BitTorrent
protocol they're intuitive notion of
prioritization is is you should ask for
the rarest piece of data first because
that's the way BitTorrent works and that
approach does in fact work it does in
fact to get the data out there however
is horrible for latency when you're
worrying about latency there's a very
very big difference between it being the
last hop and being not the last hop if
you are if you're gonna send data to
someone who is a last hop you can send
it kind at your leisure and it's not
going to make a big difference it's only
going to increase latency for just them
if you're some ending to somebody who's
not the last hop if you delay it not
only are you delaying it for them you're
delaying it for everybody they're going
to send it to as well so from a latency
standpoint you really want to send the
very most
not the the very most urgent stuff first
always first and then you want to send
it first to the peers who are going to
rebroadcast to somebody else and then
finally to the peers who aren't going to
rebroadcast to anybody else that way you
optimize your latency in principle you
could have some concept of how many hops
each peer is going to send it to I make
no such distinction here I just go last
top not last top yes I'm not quite
getting this yeah that's a small size
picture it fits on the screen yeah well
first off if you have a thousand nodes
there are going to be a little less
where around 180 peers in this group
here and this is only there's six of
these overlaid on top of each other so
this is a subset of all connections just
the ones relative to one particular Club
so when you're looking at just one Club
there's around 180 peers here 1/6 of a
thousand and there's the source which is
connected to like 3 of them and these
have a pretty random graph going between
them of where everything's going but
it's densely connected and then the
remaining eight hundred some-odd peers
are all down here and the average not
the average fan out from these peers
here for the ones down here is 5 and
there's each peer is getting data from
exactly one of those but the number of
these connections going out from these
is highly variable because that's how
the congestion control works I'll get to
that in a second does that make sense so
there's some scaling based on no there's
no scaling limit no no that the blob in
the middle increases as the number of
peers increase it's always 1/6 of the
peers a each of the other peers down
here is a member of another Club so I'm
only displaying one sixth of the total
connections of the whole thing right now
and for each of these peers down here
there'll be a member of the big cluster
for a different club
that makes sense hey it's kids in
general cut my maximum definitely of the
center Club grows very slowly oh yeah
yeah the depth that you go is going to
be basically exponential there is a
logarithmic sorry it because this is a
screamer protocol here you get this
exponential fan out in here and then you
know a factor of five for the last time
not making any sense
oh you look kind of confused okay this
is actually kind of a simpler case and
simplification of the overlays concept
which is used in other other life
protocols so there's this invariant
within your group that's screaming here
that each oh by the way these
connections are all directional there's
no bi-directional connections here if if
I'm sending you data you're probably not
sending me back the same data even if
we're both of the same called the thing
to know so there's this question of how
is the graph in here formed between
these peers and first off every peer has
at least two incoming and at least two
outgoing connections because two is the
number after one and you need that for
exponential growth I I at one point had
this as a strict invariant that every
peer had exactly two incoming and
exactly two outgoing this resulted in
state machines which were really scary
rocket science and could never quite
work exactly right do two edge cases of
peers leaving eventually I came up with
this brilliant idea that peers were
allowed to have two or three incoming in
two or three outgoing connections and
this resulted in the state machine where
if you had two or less and you get a new
one you just accept it and keep going
anybody care to guess what happens if
you have three connections and you get a
new one what you do is you take you pick
randomly one of your existing old
connections and you drop it
this can potentially make it so that the
peer that you just dropped a connection
from is now below their limit they'll go
find a new one and form a connection to
them that peer might then be above their
limit this can cascade a little bit but
because there's slop sooner or later
they'll hit someone who had extra slop
already available and the chain reaction
will stop kind of a stupid idea but it
works so did did people find what I just
said really confusing by the way was
that weird like pretty strange okay
sorry all right now so after you're done
screaming you need to send out data in a
reasonably coherent manner to the last
hop TCP is congestion window based I
hate congestion window based protocols I
think it's a horrible hack I really like
pacing out my data carefully when you're
using a congestion window you inherently
have this problem that you might maybe
be sending all your data is one giant
glop every RTT and then your queue in
the middle has to have an RT T's worth
of buffer available in it and it's just
horrible and aside from that all my
congestion control here is based on
one-way delays not packet loss and that
really gets messed up when you aren't
pacing out your data carefully so I pace
out my data meaning I send a packet at
regular intervals so because this data
is kind of known data I actually know
what it's a bit rate is the source just
says what the bit rate is and every
single piece of data coming out I don't
need to guess it I don't need to adjust
for it over the time I just say it and I
follow it you of course take the overall
data rate divided by six because each
connection is from one sixth of the data
and you multiply by the number of upload
connections you have that's the rate at
which you send data out so then you
calculate your pasting delay which is if
I didn't get any new data coming in ever
how long would it take for me to send
out all the data I've currently queued
up to send out
- then you increase your pacing to let
you increase the rate you're sending if
that data is if the pacing Billy isn't 0
based on this here formula this is an
important formula whenever you have
control loops and I have a lot of
control loops in this protocol by the
way I've learned way more about HID
controllers than I ever really cared to
in general here doing what you call AI
controllers meaning I'm doing it based
on a lot of aggregate data so you're
currently looking at your current pacing
delays very much an AI controller you
don't really ever want to rapidly change
the rate at which you send data out
because it'll mess up your own
congestion control really badly you
definitely don't want to ever send at
very much more than 25% the rate you
really should for two reasons number one
because again you'll screw up your own
congestion control peers will stop
downloading from you when they shouldn't
because you're uploading faster than you
really need to at number two there's the
subtle complicated thing where if a peer
doesn't have enough download capacity it
needs to it needs to quit eventually so
the thing that happens here this is kind
of complicated and subtle is if I'm
uploading to you and you have
insufficient download capacity I'm gonna
keep just trying to resend everything
that I'd sent you already and all these
are going to keep getting read ROPS
because your download isn't capable of
handling them your backlog is getting
keep getting gonna keep getting bigger
I'm eventually going to start sending at
25% faster than I really should be but
no more and you're gonna keep dropping
data and you're gonna keep falling
farther farther behind and eventually if
you fall too far behind you give up and
leave the swarm and that's hope yours
figure out that they have insufficient
downlink capacity kind of a hack well I
mean it works yeah anyway this is the
way you keep this from oscillating that
was a lot of work though
down to another no no no when I say
appear doesn't have sufficient download
capacity I mean the size of their down
alone pipe isn't DF okay for the bitrate
of the stream there's no like saying I'm
just gonna use a fraction of the bitrate
of the data stream here either you could
play the whole thing or eventually you
just kind of give up yes
so why do you say screamer's screamers
that's the technical term for it yes I
don't know I like the term screamer oh I
I I pulled it out of my ass if ever I'm
good at coming up with magic numbers I
have a lot of fiber in my diet
if ever you're doing your own protocol
and need some magic numbers you can come
to me I'll help you okay
no I know actually I determined it via
simulation I have this whole tricked out
system where I before I before I
actually made my code work I wrote an
emulator for the internet it turns I
spoke previously about how bad it is to
do this whatever anyway I made an
emulator for how the internet works it
turns out it's hard to simulate a tcp
because TCP stacks are different
everywhere it's actually very easy to
emulate router tree cues because they're
very simple beasts unless you're trying
to get fancy and do read or whatever the
fancy tail drop fanciness toujours is
these days I'm against that stuff it
makes me not know how the internet works
but Rodrik cues are very very simple
beasts things get delayed in transit
between peers when something hits a cue
it gets added to the end of a buffer
where everything is shoved out of on a
very regular schedule if the new packet
coming in makes the buffer too big it
gets thrown out that's how the internet
works so I wrote an emulator for that
and then I made it so all my code
all of my code has these funny things
where I have this call called dead
shuffle for deterministic shuffle where
every time I iterate over the keys in a
dictionary where the order in which I
keep iterate over the matters I first
sort and then randomly shuffle the order
of the keys so that I can run my
emulation over and over again and does
the exact same thing every time yeah and
it was in these emulations that I just
played around with the magic numbers and
came up with that as a value there there
are some trade offs to it if you have a
very very large swarm it's kind of good
to make it bigger because that makes
your overhead be lower and if you have a
very very small swarm it helps to make
it smaller so that there's more offload
to peers but that makes your overhead
larger and makes your congestion control
work worse
so 6 is pretty good on basically all
sizes it's really nice by the way I
highly recommend this having an emulator
thing I was able to like actually run
things and figure out my overall
architecture before I'd really written
much of anything like actually something
that you know spoke UDP or even actually
I'd figured out my congestion control or
for that matter on my to do list in 2009
top of the to-do list was removed
psychic powers because I had to actually
figured out my whole protocol yet and so
are there places where peers needed to
find a peer so they just went and looked
in the global data structure of all
peers and picked one you had a question
I would yeah I was going to ask how big
is a big swarm I you know that's kind of
a relative concept there are a few
different scales where things start to
behave a little bit differently okay
when you get up to what you have around
10 peers you've still likely got most of
your data or maybe like half your data
coming off the swarm source
when you get up to a hundred peers you
have most of your data coming off of
peers when you get up to around a
thousand peers you get this phenomenon
where when a peer is doing peer gossip
to find potential peers
it no longer finds out about almost all
of its potential peers that it could be
using and that affects the congestion
control in subtle ways that I'll get to
and then above a thousand peers it's all
kind of the same you can't tell the
difference yes
yeah yet you were that the bottom peers
were being booted because they didn't oh
I don't know they're down load capacity
right okay so that's what you're
measuring down load capacity wasn't very
good
you can't just notice that no no no
these are peers on the internet I don't
know anything about them they have
shitty CPU they have unload run own data
conductivity well you can look at your
data rate coming in but how do you know
whether the problem is the peers sending
you data or you're receiving data and
how do you know if the problems
transient or not and you know all that
kind of stuff you do know the rate that
you should yes but that's about all you
know there's all this like in almost
every case here you can say oh well
here's a heuristic which will really
nail it but the problem is that
heuristic only really works on a clean
network where nothing bad is happening
in bram world's bad stuff is happening
all the time you just have constant peer
churn you have constant congestion
control happening the world is out of
control I don't know like what the I
don't know what the transfer capacity of
these peers is they don't really have
great CPUs they have crosstalk going
over the same things which might or
might not be transient I don't know
what's going on with these person oh yes
how fast does peer churn occur very very
fast okay I said you're all gonna find
this hella weird here
so now you want to do congestion control
so first off don't use pipes TCP
inherently anything vaguely TCP ish has
this concept of a pipe
I'm sending you data I try to send the
data if the network isn't ready for the
data because I'm sending it too fast it
back logs it
that's not happening here I need a low
latency that that that abstraction
fundamentally introduces a lot of
latency having nothing whatsoever to do
that with the network don't use it can't
use it at all
all right well that kind of blows
anything vaguely resembling TCPS
congestion control right there so the
the fundamental construct here is
whenever you get a piece of data that's
delayed too much too much by the way
means 200 milliseconds you send a faux
ad message to the connection to the peer
that was sending you the data so ad it's
this faux ad is this universal term for
terminating a connection permanently
it's an it it's an acronym it stands for
off and die this is an actual
technical term
so hey he's a Dafoe ad message no no you
do not so the so this works well the
peer that was sending the data might
have an a backlog in their outgoing
queue which is going to cause delays for
a whole lot of peers and it's very
important to get rid of that more
important that get rid of that than to
get your own data quickly so at one
point someone new to my team we I was
someone joined my team right when we
were switching to monotonic time I by
the way don't use anything except
monotonic time this person who is new to
my team and kind of a junior coder said
well why don't you just make sure the
machines running ntp and i said okay
you're not allowed to ask that question
ever again there's this myth that
there's this thing called time that
there's this global time that's accurate
everywhere it doesn't exist in my entire
protocol there's only one place where I
call true time and
just to make it so that if you have
multiple sources they can kind of
compare to see which ones started later
so the one that started earlier can go
away but everywhere else in the entire
protocol I call monotonic time I have no
concept of what the actual time is the
only thing I know is that there are SKUs
between machines and delays and so if
I'm sending you data you can look at the
data that I got sent to you and it'll
have some delay the delay might be you
know three years and five months which
is not necessarily a useful piece of
information but if I later on send you
data which has a delay of three years
five months and 100 milliseconds you can
go oh that's a hundred milliseconds more
than before maybe there's some noise in
the network here and then if I send you
one that's a delay of three years five
months and 300 milliseconds you go oh no
that's horrible
that's too much delay I figured out some
tricks here for dealing with time time
sucks by the way I hate dealing with
time it's been weighing more time
dealing a time they were really cared to
in general a basic trick you should know
if you ever have to deal with networking
and sending timestamps or over the wire
the appropriate way of doing it is
whatever sudden someone sends you a
timestamp the way you send a timestamp
is it's two bytes which is in
milliseconds modulo two to the 16th for
every single connection or every single
peer that you get a timestamp from what
you do is you look at the last time they
sent you a timestamp and what you
thought their time was and what their
new timestamp is now and you kind of
guess about what the timestamp should be
given the current thing and you find the
nearest value modulo two to the 16th and
milliseconds that that should be this
results in this very nice behavior that
you're assumed time from a given PR at
first is something close to zero and
then it kind of just gradually increases
over time and about lockstep with you
and you don't get any threshold inking
back and forth between two values and
suddenly jumping 2 to the 16th
milliseconds or anything like that
to the sixteenth milliseconds is almost
a minute fine for my protocol because
timeouts are way quicker than that
anyway just as you know that's the right
way to do it okay so the way you find an
upir you send messages to all your
current peers saying hey tell me about
everybody you know in this club they
send you a list of everyone you know
they also help you out with some NAT
traversal they have active connections
to these beers they tell that peer hey
send a ping request to this person to
poke open a hole in net turns out enough
peers are either behind open net or have
a UPnP running that this works great you
then pick which one to download from
using this highly sophisticated
technique of picking one randomly I I
tried to be more clever about this and
in general whenever you're working on
heuristics whenever you think you're
really smart and have come up with a
heuristic for something it's always very
very important that among the heuristics
you're testing out you try the exact
opposite of what you think the right
thing to do is because that's frequently
incorrect this was one of those cases
the behavior here is not terribly
obvious let's take a very simple model
on the top here where you have a peer
and it's sending out data to its peers
and whatever appear gets you know a list
appears it just picks a random peer out
there in the swarm just start
downloading from new and then the way
the congestion control works is every
time a peer comes to its full capacity
something really horrible happens and it
drops every single connection out that
it actually has and practice it's not
quite that bad but this is a reasonable
first approximation of what's going on
then you get this pretty predictable
behavior where regardless of the
utilization regardless of the peers
upload capacity you get the rate at
which the peer is sending uploading
increasing linear
until it's 100% and then drops down to
zero now what do you notice about the
integral of this curve it's it's 50% of
the potential capacity that's not really
all that bad actually it's pretty good
in practice when you have a large swarm
and things aren't working quite so
horribly what tends to happen and again
I'm being cartoonish here is just due to
an artifact you estimate what's a big
swarm they said a thousand peers peers
will end up not knowing about every
other peer every time they do a thing in
very large swarms the peers that have
more connections will tend to get
downloaded from more just because when
you're asking for the total list of
peers they come up more often
there are various hacks that could
improve this they would likely screw
things up on small swarms I haven't
really messed with trying to fix it all
that much and let's say that the so your
cur your increase in rate instead of
being linear is a little more
exponential and then when you hit a
hundred percent it drops down to let's
say 50 percent instead of zero because
it doesn't drop every single connection
some of them drop and they drop quickly
enough that the remaining ones don't
drop and so this is more kind of what
you get and this is more the integral
this is more like 3/4 the remaining
stuff here is kind of necessary Headroom
not doing too badly actually so that's
how the congestion control works yes
this list appears how big the you just
you have like
on the order of around 10 maybe 15
connections to peers you send a message
to each of them asking for all their
peers in a club they all send responses
you send pings to all those so that's
around 100 packets with around I don't
know 30 bytes each maybe so that's three
kilobytes total for finding a new pair
it's not a big deal if you're gonna pick
one randomly why do you ask the peers
for their fullest connections to sense
just saying why don't you pick one
randomly and 71 you get 15 Oh cuz you
don't know a Phil you don't know if
you'll succeed in pinging them you don't
know you don't know if you'll succeed in
pinging them you do pave all of them
yourself make sure that natural is
working to make sure that they found up
reasonably recently okay and also yeah
that would be more you could try and
optimize this a bit but that would be
more roundtrip tiny stuff you could just
you know use the very first one that you
got but that would tend to bias towards
particular peers that have lower
latencies and stuff I suppose I could
make it so that every single peer you go
to would only send you a single one
response that wouldn't really
fundamentally change how the overall
protocol works though just because in
the case where you only wind up getting
a few peers in your responses your
overall behavior is gonna be the same
anyway and you're gonna have to wait the
same amount of time before picking one
so oh it just waits a second before
picking one so it doesn't have it
doesn't have any concept of checking to
see if it's got all of its responses it
just waits a second after it started the
whole process before picking one and if
it doesn't have a list of them it just
starts the process over again at that
point this is in many ways not a very
sophisticated protocol it's all PACs and
emergent behavior okay now you need to
prioritize your data like I said before
you want to send your in Club data first
so let's say that you have six outgoing
connections and this
saying what pieces of data the peers
need these are related latest piece of
data you've gotten and these are earlier
pieces of data and you're in clunkers
already have most of the data you're out
of club peers don't have quite so much
of the data and the order in which you
send data to them is the order in which
I've numbered here you round-robin
between peers the idea being that each
peer should keep the current latency
that it has if one peer is playing with
very low latency you want to send it
stuff relatively quickly
if one pur is playing with high latency
it's okay to take longer to send it
stuff round-robin appears preserves that
across peers and of course you you send
the earlier data first and and well
that's what you do here so you see it
goes I've numbered them one two three
four five six and just sticking with in
club and round-robin hang and then it
goes to the out of Club and goes 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21
reasonably straightforward
of course it's unlikely that you would
go that whole whole entire time without
getting any new data in but that's the
order you'd go if you never got any new
data the whole time you're sending those
out oh by the way I didn't do these
beautiful diagrams you might have
gathered by my difficulty of setting
things up I don't really do a V at all
some people I work with decided I should
have better presentations so they
insisted that I scroll some diagrams
with it which actual professionals who I
work with made into these very pretty
diagrams you see here they should be
iterated on a bit more but thanks to
taka on my team for actually making this
looks nice so there's an exception to
this you get this case again this is
something that I found in the emulator
which would have really been which is
hard enough to find in the emulator who
have been a real nightmare to try and
find out a running system you can get
this interesting phenomenon where the
source only has one out of Club outgoing
connection
and that outgoing connection gets
starved out this can be very very bad
because that one pier is just gonna not
play ever so to get rid of that problem
you have this exception where you make
sure every tenth packet is out of clubs
so this is a case here where you have
just the one out of club connection and
you see it is round-robin again in club
but after it gets to nine it just sends
number 10 out of club just literally if
it just sent nine in club in a row
number 10 goes out of club and that goes
back to normal prioritization kind of
hack it works prevent some really bad
sturbation that could happen in case
you're wondering how I got the every
tenth packet same thing as before I did
actually test it and wound up using 1
out of 10 I'm pretty good at that little
game of making up numbers yes
you got early in the morning at
breakfast to notice these things or you
have some way of systemic point
systematic way of finding them I run
emulated tests which display eivol yes I
I ball them they have all kinds of
numbers that they spit out and stuff as
they're running and which is utterly
inscrutable to everyone but me and
someone on my team is actually adding
headers and stuff to label what
everything is so you can see what's
going on
and I noticed bad things happening like
I'll just run a situation and notice
that's really an emulation because the
peers don't the peers don't know that
they're in a computer
the I'll notice that like one peer has
very high latency or that one peer quit
which didn't make any sense because
there's plenty of bandwidth or it seems
like there should be plenty of bandwidth
so long ago well what if I increase so
there's plenty of bed with everyone then
still happens oh how that happened I
start running at her sometimes I'll have
something which only happens in one run
but because I have this magical
deterministic emulation I can do that
run over and over and over again and
really figure out exactly what's going
on that's how I find this stuff I find
the thought of trying to like do this
without that like nightmarish horrifying
I would never even try yes
Hubbs I talked about club sorry you said
like these guys are in one club and
there are other clubs but you didn't
really talk about your buddy
there's six clubs oh okay that's it
every peer is a member of one club
okay that's all there is to say about
this okay well when a new peer comes in
and picks a random club to be a member
of okay in order to try and make it so
there's approximately equal numbers of
peers in every club the tracker will
give a hints the way the tracker gives a
hint is it takes the last tint it handed
out and adds one to it okay finally you
reconstruct your data and play back
which is kind of a trivial thing well
actually no it's not trivial it's
horrible the this is a lot to do with
time again and local CPU delays and who
knows what so - first approximation you
don't do skips ever just you get data
comes in and you play it out if the next
piece of data that you're scheduled to
play isn't here locally you wait for it
and then you play and you reset your
delay to now be based on how long it
took for you to get the data so it's
your new latency you of course can't do
that at the very start you need to
decide when it's okay to start this is
how you decide when it's okay to start
you I don't know if you can see I'm
numbering the packets from the upper
left just counting in read order down to
the lower right this is typically the
spread of packets that you'll get you're
downloading from peers who start sending
you at differing points they send you
everything sequentially you get these
kind of vertical stripes of stuff as
soon as you have six contiguous packets
in this case it would start at 78 over
here because 78 through 83 is six
contiguous packets you start playing
there that's where you start your
reconstruction and then you start
playback
I hate CPU delays
whenever you get data whenever you wake
up from asleep you don't generally wake
up when you asked to you wake up later
sometimes you wake up earlier especially
in Windows machines anyway I'm not
kidding you always always always
remember when it was you were supposed
to wake up
so you wake up to send a piece of data
you just send a piece of data out for
playback and then you schedule the next
piece of data to be sent out but you
schedule it when it was supposed to
happen not based on the Delta in time
from the current one to that one because
you need to correct for CPU delays
there's a very very big exception to
this which is if you didn't have any
data to send out before and you do now
cuz you'd caught up then you send the
next piece of data you because you were
waiting for the next piece of data you
then send it out immediately and set the
playback delay to be the current delay
based on that one piece of data CPU
delays be damned
it took me way too long to figure that
out
that's the right way of doing things so
you can't completely get away without
having skips forever you do occasionally
actually lose a piece of data the and
you and just no amount of just waiting
for it will make it well they could come
in to account for that if you are frozen
I said I should say frozen rather than
delayed but if you're frozen for more
than two seconds you go into desperation
mode which basically is the mode that
you started with when you first started
to playback in the first place and
occasionally you can run into a
situation where you got delayed a large
amount at some time in the distant past
and that append you continued playing at
a high delay ever since then
and it seems like it's not necessary
anymore you don't have any terribly good
options here you can keep playing at a
high latency forever
you can skip a couple of seconds of
video or you can playback sped up I
playback sped up currently set to 10% I
should probably change it to five all
right finally after that thing that by
the way it had to do with what I call
the smoother hate working on the
smoother most hated part of my own code
base
finally you wait for a keyframe I
mentioned this because it sucks
keyframes are typically people don't
like putting keyframes in their video
because it hurts the compression on
their video as a result of which you
will typically get keyframes every I
don't know 8 16 seconds which results in
waiting for a keyframe to do your
playback like literally my protocol is
working great it's getting the data it's
ready to play the data it's sitting
there waiting for a keyframe so it takes
like eight seconds to start playback and
the user thinks it's playing with a
delay of eight seconds no it's playing
with a delay of three seconds I just had
to wait six seconds for a keyframe after
I actually started my playback it sucks
this is kind of a deep problem in
general it's the reason why changing
channels on cable sucks by the way they
don't like sending keyframes either they
do send keyframes every like second just
so that it doesn't just freeze everytime
you change channels because they have
this problem too but when you're just
flipping channels you definitely notice
it that's why it takes longer to change
channels now than it did 20 years ago in
case you were wondering latency is in
general have gone have slid backwards
horribly across the board people
interrupt each other on the phone all
the time these days and it's not that
people have gotten more rude oh I
suppose they probably have it's because
the round-trip time on phone calls has
gone up it turns out
round-trip time of a third of a second
on a phone call is kind of manageable
turns out by an interesting cosmic
coincidence due to the speed of light
you kind of need close to a third of a
second RTT on a phone call if you're
going between New Zealand and Spain I
think they should just plumb a line
through the center of the earth I'm told
that's got some engineering challenges
to it but but even if you're in the same
city see the telcos decided and their
infinite wisdom that a third of a second
was acceptable or a third of second was
good a third of a second is not good
okay like less than a hundred
milliseconds for a human voice call kind
of okay more than that it starts getting
annoying and a third of a second is like
just on the edge of totally and utterly
unacceptable so if you notice that
whenever you talk to people on cell
phones and they're on cell phones which
is every call ever of these days even
when you're on the city same city you
have this horrible round trip time on it
and you'll be interrupting each other
all the time because you stop talking to
give the other person a chance to talk
you wait 200 milliseconds which is
plenty of time for them to respond they
haven't responded yet because they
haven't heard you stop talking and then
you start talking again and then they
start talking over you and that's why
people interrupt each other and calls
all the time you notice this like a mob
el Park I don't know what's called these
days it's obviously more on Bell Park
so what's called Ma Bell Park if you're
watching the game and watching one of
the videos they have there there there
will be a video of the game that's
happening a hundred feet away from you
it's delayed by like two seconds like
right there it used to be you could sit
in a baseball stadium not that I watch
baseball but you could sit in a baseball
stadium and if you were sitting back in
the bleachers you could be listening to
the radio and you would hear calls and
what was happening in front of you
before the sound of the play got to your
ears but after you you know saw it
visually because it turns out the speed
of sound isn't really all that fast and
it's quite noticeable when you're in the
back bleachers that don't that trick
don't work no more it turns out if you
really really want to optimize
for latency well when truly like
optimize for latency across the board
you basically go back and build the same
that we had the 1950's is the way
you optimize for legacy everywhere just
no processing in the middle of anything
no compression no nothing just straight
through analog gets great latency also
really good if you want space aliens to
be watching your TV programs very very
hard for space aliens to see anything if
everyone's getting it over their local
wireless because it's not loud enough
for them to see other giant telescopes
anyway let's see enough ranting about
the lace the so it's a proper change
account and that's all I had to say
actually so that's that's my talk does
anyone have any questions as I put
together and I will put together more in
the future I'm also planning on making
the codebase available for the purposes
of academic study there's patent it's
half right because it's kind of a moving
target and it's not it's written kind of
in panties but what you just saw is
about as much information as it's
generally available now so if you have
any questions you can ask yes yes I got
the other because you kept you kept
dropping in these little this is what
you think you should do no don't do this
ha scared of doing a paper on this how
many paper on how to do this I'm not
sure what you need
well you said okay I build build an
emulator of the yeah and study always
try the opposite yeah I guess yeah the
the emulator is with my codebase
actually and it is a really dumb piece
of code
and people who actually know how the
internet works cringe horribly when I
tell them the model of the Internet and
Bram world but see in Bram world the
backbone is infinite capacity and you're
Layton sees come from a few places
there's pacing delay on the actual
appears because it doesn't send out data
just because it doesn't feel like it
because it's running Windows because I
don't know it doesn't send it out for a
while and then you have queuing delays
on the router which data gets to
basically instantaneously which can be
like a couple seconds long and there can
be buffer bloat and yada yada yada on
that and and then once data gets off of
that has a little bit of serialization
delay going out that's very small and
then most under good conditions most of
the latency comes from the next thing
which has to do with the speed of light
everyone just kind of assumes that
there's all this delay in routing turns
out it's not well delay in routing is in
microseconds delay due to the speed of
light is in milliseconds the speed of
light isn't really all that fast if
someone can figure out how to make the
speed of light just like one order of
magnitude faster it would really make my
life a lot easier
either move everyone back onto the same
continent or make the speed of light one
order of magnitude quicker would really
just eliminate huge number of
engineering challenges for me and then
you hit another queue on the receiving
end and then some one place I think my
emulator doesn't actually emulate a
queue on the receiving end it just
assumes they're all superfast anyway in
Bram world the backbone internet
capacity is infinite so yes here you
know it is not no it wouldn't really do
me any good in practice these things
tend to be dominated by one
implementation anyway and I really want
to maintain the ability to rev it over
time
and also unlike BitTorrent protocol this
isn't really that resilient it appears
being misbehaved so it's pretty easy to
write a peer that just doesn't really
behave all that well and kind of screws
up things for everybody else so I want
to maintain a certain amount of con
all thanks yes because on large networks
not ten million I've tried it on you
know thousands we've had networks of
thousands of actual appears in the wild
actually watching something of their own
free will we also ran a whole bunch on
ec2 which is you know kind of an
artificial situation I think we only got
up to like eight thousand peers on it
because we used all the available you
see two instances at that moment but but
that were we were able to get that to
work fine as well that was also a very
useful form of testing to do but yeah
the the we've gotten up to a scale where
I don't anticipate any changes as it
gets larger really yeah you try to
compare it against other products like
stream torn and beetle and other it's if
they're not even comparable it's it's a
blowout yes what is why we're TC it's
just like peer to peer in the browser
it's a new web standard oh oh that stuff
isn't really useful for me because
that's for like point-to-point video and
I need actual connections myself I
basically need to be able to send UDP
traffic if I can't actually send UDP
traffic I can't do my protocol I try to
get it all back I just do reso's so like
there's all this stuff on being able to
handle packet loss which isn't really
that useful for what I'm doing it's
really useful if you're doing an
interactive like video chat with
somebody yeah but there you're talking
about you know less than a third of
second round trip time and here my
delays are like on the order of around
five seconds you know hopefully less but
could be around five seconds and that
gives you enough time to ask for a reset
and things like that so you have this
failover time in the middle
- you're looking for in television which
is that if you glitched a second or two
well you know what television I a yeah I
appear to actually glitch a lot less
than like YouTube does okay definitely a
lot less than most streaming services do
it's actually really hard to get your
glitching under control in general so
I'm very very conservative about making
it so that when you do get glitches
there freezes and then they happen very
very rarely that you get a freeze and
then you don't get a freeze again for a
really really long time
where other things will actually drop
data and stuff and I really really try
hard to never actually drop data you
always get the data it just might be
delay a little bit and you always get it
on exactly the schedule that you should
or other things try and play games or
they get down to the wire and stuff and
I'm not about doing that being a lot
more conservative yes because I guess
each peer used to have about 10 times as
much no no no each peer should probably
really have around let's say a third of
the bitrate in upstream capacity you can
get away with less on individual peers
but they'll have constant churn it's
kind of annoying the source should have
ten times the source really should have
four times but it caps itself at ten by
default so great now it's capping us I
was 20 but what is that
is that amount this you know practice
both for alone you know if a lot of
people are blocking it on cellphones or
something is that cellphones are kind of
under be tolerant oh well wireless net
connection wireless network aynd of a
problem they be here really really badly
in particular they have crazy erratic
ping times I don't even know how they
manage to pull that off but they do like
I don't like even if you have high loss
it doesn't cause high ping times I do
not know what they're doing it to cause
erratic ping times that makes no sense
transmission yeah oh okay they should
see that they should stop doing that
they complain about us just as much okay
all right fine yeah anyway the so it
only really works when you're on Wi-Fi
or a reasonable net connection of some
kind
the oh oh in culvert when am piers oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no no that it
doesn't have congestion super only it
does in fact have congestion control so
in order to for its in club data each
pier needs some minimum amount of
connectivity in principle if a pier
discovered that was really bad it could
just kind of not even do in club but
it's rare for upload/download ratios to
be so off that a peer that can't even
handle that will actually be able to
even watch the stream so they tend to
kick themselves out completely but
appear will happily only do it's in
clogged conductivity and have zero out
of code connections going out and that
will cause other peers to have more out
of club connections going in coming you
do not outgoing
so each peer will have two or three
incoming a two or three outgoing in club
and then out of club middle of five
incoming and between zero and infinity
outgoing and generally fast computers
have a lot about going it still appears
have many fewer and that's how the
congestion control arcs and then it's
it's very very noisy I've got a lot of
firewalls would freak out about this
really badly because it exhibits churn
rates which are not supposed to happen
in any known protocol
yes this support like took video quality
changing depending on the user's
connection speed I know so it's just
whatever the broadcaster decides to
Brian yeah you couldn't you can
broadcast to different swarms of
different bit rates which is what tends
to be done in fact even things like just
a nut TV tend to just give you two
options and then if one kicks out you is
the user go oh I want the other one
but the fragments that immigrants it
then they have half as many people I
well each peer brings its own upload
capacity with its own download demand so
the fragmentation isn't really a problem
or anything okay adds a little bit in
requirements to the source in terms of
having two things that it needs to
source no that's not that big of a deal
you